[Music]
probably my boldest choice was when I
made a decision to dispute the FDA and I
was on this course
you know it's pretty straightforward you
have a pre-specified endpoints you go
out and do the studies you meet them
with statistical significance you get to
an approval provided there are no snow
Stoppers and so I had gone out I've
gotten this drug from the company that
first first developed it I'd sat down
with the FDA what do I need to do we'd
agreed I'd gone out I'd done the work
I'd gotten the outcomes mm-hmm we got
rejected what was the drug this was um a
D which is a dy weii yes so at that
moment it could have it was crippling
for my business like we had done the
work we had done all the right things
scientifically and yet we got to an O
and I was faced with turning back to
shareholders and saying this is gonna be
this many million more dollars at that
time I was lucky a woman reached out to
me and you know people knew we were on
this on this journey just for context
for listening this is your second
company it is yeah sprout
pharmaceuticals thought of or dubbed by
the media the product at least as Female
Viagra
where people are yes trying to keep
track okay so so you know people knew
that we were going down this path and I
think that it was so fortuitous that she
reached out to me at this moment and
said don't give up I was on the drug in
the research trials I want to share my
story with you hmm
she lived outside of DC I was in DC all
the time I went to have a coffee with
her she walked into the room and you
know this woman was in charge
Taipei recognized it right away you know
she walked over she had her own business
she'd raised two beautiful boys she had
what looked like the perfect marriage by
all our normal standards she said I have
succeeded in every aspect of my life
other than this
I'm waiting every day for my husband to
ask me for a divorce and I'm looking at
this woman and I got no sex life or like
yeah she had no interest so she had this
she had been diagnosed with this
condition what is the condition it's
called hypoactive sexual desire disorder
HSDD is the moniker same
as IDI has for men so IDI is the most
common male sexual dysfunction H STD is
women's most common and it's a lack of
interest in having sex and I think in
categories where we have we have natural
by unconscious bias will call it
unconscious conscious unconscious bias
you really do have to spend time with
the people who are affected by it so
even if you look at things like AIDS it
took the patient voice for us to really
appreciate what needed to happen our job
as a drug company is to characterize the
benefits and the risks with great rigor
in trials ultimately the FDA's job is to
protect patient safety if there's a
showstopper in there but otherwise it is
to turn that decision over to patients
and the providers and because of again I
think all of that feelings we have about
sex I was told all the time said this
earlier Cyndi why are you such a
crusader in this nobody's going to lose
their life from this and what I said is
go spend time with these women they're
losing their life as they know it it's
breaking up their marriages it's
affecting how they feel about themselves
you know our sex is a lot of how we show
up in the world our moxie and if it
breaks down in the bedroom it is
breaking down over the breakfast table
you